coming down to the final tally of the  votes I believe it's gonna be a very  tight race marks very popular Paul's  very popular Bob is gaining in  popularity by the minute and Jim while  he's become so popular it's just crazy  in third with 2500 votes Mike yeah oh  come it that's fantastic  you got nominee for an Oscar what do you  care about being the most famous sibling  you got nominated for an Oscar second  2,700 votes Donny just let it go  this election is raped this is rape in  the winter what do you think  the win it's all over I'm the real deal  don't care oh you won huh  you won him he Belle Epoque  I did not I did no such thing currently  I won and I just really feel one more  crushing blow to Donny Bob unfortunately  came in for solid fourth on close very  close  I don't mind losing to anybody but Donna  just because he wanted so much as i  concerned they're all winners